bon alors on parle un petit peu de vous
je disais que vous avez 24 ans
vous êtes nîmoise comme vous que louis
jeanne van par les jeunes salésienne bon
mais pas voter de nîmes il évoquera de
champ mais mon accent je les relations
parfaitement de nîmes oui et puis voilà
simplement bon alors c'est pas un métier
facile le métier de comédienne mais
tellement agréable et alors vous ne
touchez pas non
alors vous allez comme ça
vous avez dit je ne serais pas fier de
moi si je décroche un rôle parce que
j'ai couché
elles disent tout ça je ne couche pas
bernard tu voulais rajouter non rien
j'ai dans mon village qui sont très
exiguës et quand tu es obligé de passer
les uns devant les autres bon alors bon
il faut quand même remettre les pendules
à l'heure et c'est pas la peine d'avoir
comme ça des espoirs déçus chaque soir à
la sortie du théâtre un beau jeune homme
vient vous chercher c'est votre fiancée
ouais il est acteur il vient tous les
soirs tous les soirs il vient me
chercher il n'y a pas un jour ne vient
pas
quand ils travaillent oui bon quel
serait le personnage que vous aimeriez
jouer quel est votre rêve pour elle
c'est célimène à dans le misanthrope à
la trappe oui j'avais vraiment très
envie de jouer tiens je vous prends au
mot allez vous avez quelques verres de
shelly manne joaillier cousin
mois renoncer au monde avant que de
vieillir et dans votre désert aliments
se veut lire un solitude et frey une âme
de 20 ans je me sens pas la mienne assez
grande assez forte pour moi
mon texte à l'heure
pour me résoudre à prendre un dessin de
la sorte voilà c'est
[Applaudissements]
très difficile selon lui demander
50 comme ça dit la clé j'ai voulu le
piéger ah je vous tiendrais tout à
l'heure je crois oui abbès oeil et rock
est ce que c'est vrai que vous avez
horreur des comédiens qui se plaignent
oui parce que je trouve qu'on fait on
fait un métier qui est extraordinaire
oui et
et je vois pas en quoi on peut se
plaindre on a toujours eu envie enfin je
crois que c'est un métier où on a envie
de le faire on est passionné de ça et se
plaindre j'accroche ambitieuse
ambitieuse oui forcément j'ai envie
d'ambitieuses dans le sens que j'ai
envie d'avoir des rôles qui
m'intéressent jouer des personnages
abbas et
et surtout qu'on assiste à ce qui est
mal en échange du théâtre de la
philosophie et la poésie à la balle
puisque je vous vois sous le charme si
vous aviez une seule question une
question très courte à poser à alexandra
lamy aller et chalets et regardez là
c'est à moi qu'il faut dernier
et ce qu'est vous saurez est ce que vous
aimez réémet follement
seulement voilà voilà c'est triste parce
que vous n'avez plus de chance
puisqu'elle aime follement oui la place
est prise à rabal faut faire
qu'est-ce qu'il ya bernard est
tous bons
alexandra donc là vous entendez bien
avec vos deux compères combien d'heures
oui moi je vous ai vu aussi dans des
spots publicitaires oui ça c'est pour
gagner votre vie oui oui non la plume
marie patry vous avez vous avez fait la
publicité un fromage
ouais mais vous n'avez pas de mauvaise
conscience à faire ce genre de choses
non non non c'est juste comme ça alors
vous rester auprès de georges guétary
voulu donner la main s'il est seul voilà
et
[Musique]